good evening this is my story this is my
song these are the words in blessed
assurance and I remember being on
Broadway watching Cicely Tyson on stage
sing those words and as I sat there i
started thinking about how amazing that
is so when I sort of think about what I
would say today I started to think about
those exact words this is my story this
is my song for those of you who don't
know
African Americans hold Sicily in such
high regard she is a queen to us we bow
to her
and it's not just because she was very
selective about the roles that she chose
over the years because she would only do
roles that served us as
african-americans it's not just because
she was an activist or a philanthropist
but it's because she was such a great
example an amazing woman with a good
heart and a good soul and we honor her
for just being who she is so when I
think about her life span you have to
understand this this is what's so
fascinating to me when she started this
business
it was Hattie McDaniels who had just won
the Oscar but she wasn't allowed to sit
down front she had to sit in the back of
the room first african-american to win
an Academy Award
she knew Josephine Baker she'd met
Josephine Baker she met Dorothy
Dandridge she was friends with Lena
Horne
she married Miles Davis I mean come on
so with all of that said I kept thinking
about that story this is my story this
is my song the day she called me and she
told me that she was going to get this
honor we sat on the phone for a while
and she was in tears I could hear it
because I can only imagine this woman
starting her career when black people
were not even allowed to come in to
front doors
wait I'm getting emotional thinking
about this because at that moment on the
phone was so powerful for me because
there she was having to do ten times as
much work and be paid a hundred times
less but she kept a smile about herself
she kept her wit she kept her way she
kept her class she kept her grades she
kept representing us and she remained
Cicely Tyson so for that
for that we thank you and I gotta say to
the Board of Governors my heart is so
full right now because I'm so grateful
and thankful to you for voting for this
woman because she so deserves it
she's so deserving it's been a long time
coming and as you go through the night
and you sing that song
blessed assurance praising my Savior all
the day long this is my story this is my
song here's another word you can add to
that song when you talk about your story
and that is oscar god bless you I love
you darling I love you so much